ce 10 mai siad qu'il aille voir à
l'hyper cacher s'il n'était pas content
qu hier un immigré nord africain pour
les sauver voilà donc c'est les
amalgames à la con qui j -louis je
trouve que la famille et digne excusez
moi je suis la famille et digne dans la
dans la dans l'extrême douleur dans le
excusez moi c'est que je sais que vous
êtes vous êtes très proche de bernard
aussi c'était la famille donc j'ai du
mal à du mal je trouve qu'ils sont d'une
extrême dignité dans la violence de ce
qu'ils ont vécu et c'est sur ça ajoute
encore à l'émotion qui est une émotion
à part quelques imbéciles tout le monde
est avec vous totalement gelos et vous
avez une relation particulière avec
bernard tapie
quand vous avez appris ça vous si j'ai
depuis que j'ai appris ça c'est comme si
c'était ma famille comme si comme si
c'était mais mes parents je suis
bouleversée c'est horrible de faire ça
c'est horrible horrible horrible l'appât
du gain ce que c'est moche mais voilà il
ya plein de gens il ya plein de gens à
qui ça arrive et qui ont voilà pas eu
assez de chance d'avoir tout ce soutien
parce qu'un soutien comme ça qu'ils
soient d'anonymes sur les réseaux pour
le coup une fois pour une fois les
réseaux bases étaient bienveillants et
puis le président ça fait du bien ça
fait du bien de te sentir aimé après
avoir eu cette violence est là tu te dis
merde il ya quand même d'autres gens à
qui ça arrive et ils n'ont pas cette
bienveillance là donc il faut il faut
penser à eux il faut surtout penser à
eux pas se plaindre nous et ça va ils
sont rentrés à la maison
c'est des coups et basses et des coûts
c'est des coups quelques coups de plus
ils font plus mal cela physiquement au
départ après c'est un peu moralement
mais bon il faut penser à ces gens à qui
n'ont pas la chance de que nous on a
entre guillemets d'être aussi bien en
tout est faux au jour d'aujourd'hui il
ya forcément un traumatisme
bernard et dominique ils sont aux fruits
des mesures de sécurité ils ont fait des
dons il ya dix normales comme dans non
non ils n'ont plus dormir hier soir non
j'étais compliqué compliqué de compliqué
mais je sais que le président a mis en
place un système de sécurité de son fait
lui qui l'a décidé personne ne lui a
demandé au québec mais bienveillante
sabri par bienveillance
voilà et madame mag on a été très classe
elle vous à vous l'avez eu plusieurs
fois et c'est une grande dame pour
prendre des nouvelles a appris pour elle
c'est vraiment une grande dame et aucun
racolage politique là dedans c'est vrai
que c'est très sincèrement cloche c'est
vraiment une grande dame